hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the king's gambit
modern defense the kings game bit my
favorite opening in all of chess starts
out with e4 e5 and then white plays f4
giving up upon in exchange for rapid
development and some strong attacks
against black now the modern defense
comes from the accepted line which is
pawn takes on
f4 then knight to f3 rapid development
from white
but black now strikes the center with
pawn d5 and it has the same idea as the
fischer defense which is pawn d6 to open
up for the light square bishop to get
involved but d5 says
i'm just going to give back that pawn in
material for my own rapid development
and i don't care about the extra pawn i
want to make sure that white's not the
one with all of the initiative now
almost 95 percent of the time white is
going to take on d5 so in this video we
are going to look at what happens when
white takes we are going to play knight
to f6 development move for our knight
controls the center of the board attacks
this pawn on
d5 so the variations in this video we're
going to be covering the first one is c4
holding down this d5 pawn we're also
going to look at knight to c3
also trying to control this d5 square
you can start to see a theme here bishop
to c4 controlling this d5 square and
then lastly if they don't even want to
try to control that at all and just give
us that material that's fine maybe
bishop to b5
that says hey this is check you can't
play your normal knight to c6 if you
want to block off some of your materials
like bishop to d7 that's fine as well so
we'll look at that
so those are the four variations that
we're going to look at in today's king's
gambit modern defense video
the first version we're going to look at
is if white plays c4 now i think this is
the best line for white but white also
has to worry about
a pretty bad pawn structure later in the
game and i think they end up losing a
lot of end games because of this they
end up with an isolated d-pawn and so
for this reason it is very tricky even
though it is what i think is the best
line we're always going to be playing
pawn to c6 trying to uh put this in a
tough spot you always want to be
attacking
these central pawns here and so doing
that with c6 makes a lot of sense i
don't think they're really going to be
taking here if they do hey that's great
for us we can capture material while
developing our knights and so from here
you know if they play d4 opening up for
their dark square bishop to take our
pawn on f4
then we can just play bishop to b4
attacking their king
maybe knight c3 castle on the king side
again we don't even care about uh giving
up some of this material we have so many
strong attacks here they're knights
being pinned down by our bishop to the
king we have both of our knight and our
queen attacking this pawn right here we
can get our light square bishop involved
into the game pinning down their knight
so this is a pretty good spot i just
don't see white playing uh this poorly
so instead of just taking our pawn on c6
i do think there are some other options
one would just be knight to c3
just building up pressure on this d5
square
if that's the case we're just gonna go
ahead and take and one of the threats
that we have here as soon as we take
is they always have to respond to our
threats we are the one with the
initiative now when typically when you
think of the king's gambit white always
has the initiative
meaning that let's say
white plays bishop d2 they look at the
fact that we're being the aggressor and
so they want to castle on the king's
side get some safety well we can start
to really put a lot of pressure on our
opponent d4 now
attacks this knight the knight doesn't
have a lot of great squares you can see
the knight can't capture it because our
queen would just come up in recapture so
that would be a pretty terrible spot if
they play something you know knight to
d5
we can just go ahead and take they take
now our queen takes on d5
and the queen in the center of the board
usually is met with a knight coming to
you know c3 attacking our queen pushing
him back but now they don't have that
option now our queen is in the middle of
the board we have a lot of pressure both
of our pawns have crossed the halfway
point and you can see they're they're
kind of stuck the dark square bishop it
can't move anywhere it's blocked by its
own pawns this bishop on e2 is blocked
by the knight here and so white has kind
of a tough spot of how to actually get
out of here black on the other side can
easily develop all of its material can
cast on the king side get some king
safety so this is going to be pretty
easy
i think development win for for black if
they try something different maybe
instead of knight coming to
d5 maybe they say
we can go ahead and check our opponents
here queen to a4
but then we can easily just stop that
bishop to d7 now this is a somewhat uh
interesting line it gets somewhat
complicated if they find this i don't
think they they always would but knight
to b5 stopping that pawn to a6
and then pawn d3 we can't just take it
right away because then they could take
our rook on a8 but instead
we can just play knight to c6 this now
opens up now we can take the knight so
the knight has to move but then we can
just go ahead and play bishop to b4
check
now bishop to d2 we can exchange here we
can go ahead and castle on the king side
maybe they castle we play queen to e7
attacking this bishop on uh e2
and i think this is a much better setup
for
for black so
that's what's going to happen if we see
them not really responding to our
initiative and try to play it safe they
really need to attack us
back not play something
real quiet like bishop to e2 so instead
i think they really should just be
taking our pawn on
d5 if that's the case we're always going
to respond by taking with our knight not
going to take with our queen obviously
that would be terrible they could just
take our queen here but now they have
some options if they take with their
knight i think this is bad as well for
many of the same reasons we take with
our queen and we have a central queen
while we have the initiative and they
can't force our queen away
now if they decide that we're putting
too much pressure so they want to try to
counter attack maybe queen to a4 check
we're gonna play knight to c6 getting
more material involved into the game
also stopping their threat queen takes
on f4 yes they have equalized in
material but now let's start to look at
the position here
both sides have five pawns but white
hasn't isolated upon the d-file it's
going to be a weakness for them they
have to worry about if they cast on the
king side they're they're still gonna
have a weakened king the f pawn's not
there and black has the initiative so
even if white plays you know d4 trying
to counter in the center of the board
get their dark square bishop involved
black can castle on the queen side and
put max pressure on the opponent doesn't
even have to play it safe and castle on
the king's side so always look at your
chess games and figure out if you have
the initiative how can you continue to
be aggressive not just castle king side
because you think you always have to
have castle king's side sometimes you
actually want to castle queen titan this
is a prime example of what that looks
like now if we come back maybe they
don't take with their their knights
maybe they decide to play something else
bishop two c4
attacking this knight okay well i
recommend playing knight to b6 now the
reason for this is
our knight's under attack
we can take their knight on c3 but i
think this lets them off the hook the
reason for that is they can take with
their pawn and they've now solved their
problem of the weak pawn on the d-file
this isolated pawn i don't like to let
my opponent off the hook and so because
of that i like to maintain pressure so
knight to b6 still attacks our opponent
on c4 it also keeps the pressure with
our queen open
both of our bishops can get involved
into the game and we still have their
dark square bishop completely blocked
off okay well how do they respond from
here if they play bishop to b5 check
okay sure we can go and play bishop d7
they can trade off if they want to
that's completely fine
if they bring their
bishop back let's say bishop comes back
to b3
then i like playing knight to
c6 the reason i like knight c6
instead of you know something bishop d6
preparing to castle on the king side
is because if they play queen to e2 i'd
rather play bishop to e7 in the spot and
i don't want a wasted move i'd rather
have knight to
uh be
c6 so here knight to c6 and now if they
want to play queen to e2 now i can play
bishop to e7 so it makes sure that they
don't take away any of my tempo
in the game
so if we come back early on that was
what happens
if they play that knight c3 another
option is to completely avoid what we're
doing and play d4 say if we're going to
capture black's material back let's go
ahead and control the center of the
board and then if they want to worry
about this d5 pawn we can just come and
capture the pawn on f4
if they played d4 we are just
immediately going to take on d5 and they
really have two main options here one is
just taking on f4 as we talked about
saying i'm not going to worry about the
d5 pawn i'm going to get that material
back on f4 and get my dark square bishop
involved into the game from here that we
could play bishop to b4 we've
essentially forced them to play knight
to c3 it's kind of awkward if you play
bishop to f4 and then bring it back to
d2 so typically you'll see knight to c3
but we only have to take here we can
just maintain the pressure reminder that
the bishop on f1 the light square bishop
has to move before they can castle on
the king side and so this is really just
pinning down this knight we can go ahead
and castle on the king side if we want
to we have great safety here for our
king and then we can get our other
material involved into the game we need
our license bishop involved into the
game we could play knight to c6 we can
take here on c4 so we have lots of good
options now if they don't take on f4
another thing that they could try is
c5 just extend on the queen side of the
board they still have the option to
attack
on f4 but this says hey we're not going
to allow you to play bishop to d6 and
hold down that pawn on f4 so that's one
option that they
that they could try
in this case we're going to play pawn to
b6 and just try to blow this up
and it's very difficult for them to
really hold on to this and so that's why
i like this it also opens up for us to
get our light square bishop to some
other squares we can always play knight
to c6 still attack this square on d4 so
that's how i would approach it
the the next option those were all if
they play
c4 early on in the game the next version
we're going to look at is if they play
knight 2 c 3.
just remember in the modern defense if
they don't protect this pawn on d5 with
the pond we're pretty much gonna be
taking this pawn on d5 with our knight
so we're gonna take on d5 look at a
couple options if they decide to go and
take with their knight that's fine we
take with our queen and as we looked at
in some previous variations it's very
difficult for them to actually deal with
this queen in the center of the board
typically they like to bring their
knight to c3 with development and kick
our queen back but that knight is gone
so how do they really respond okay if
they play
pawn d4
opening up for the dark square bishop to
attack the pawn on f4
we have a couple ways to
approach this but remember we can now be
the aggressor in the game
so we can put max pressure on our
opponent so in that case i recommend
playing g5 if we want to castle we can
still castle on the queen side but this
i think is the best way to actually
protect this pawn on f4 and we can start
marching up the board if we want to pawn
2 g4 at some point as well really
depends on where our opponent goes now
let's say they don't
take with their knights early on maybe
they play bishop to c4
that's fine now we can go ahead and take
their knight on c3 notice how this is a
much different setup than before where i
didn't like taking the knight on c3
because i i thought it left them off the
hook by destroying their pawn chain
in this situation
it's not actually blowing up their pawn
chain
instead once we take they can take with
their pawn we can take exchange queens
off the board and then after bishop to
d6 you can see that black is now up a
pawn in material white has double pawns
on the c file and the queens have come
off the board
black has a clear advantage typically
white's playing the king's gambit to
give up a pawn so that they have a
really strong attack
we've pretty much negated the entire
attack we've come out with the pawn and
we actually have a better setup so black
should have a pretty easy game
coming out of here so that's what
happens if they played knight to c3
early on i don't think it's a very good
way to approach it but you definitely
could see it it's gonna be similar to if
they play bishop to c4 same thing if
they don't protect it with the pawn
we're pretty much always just gonna be
taking with our knight on d5
so once we take let's look at their
options if they take with their bishop
okay we can take with our queen the main
difference here is they actually can
play knight to c3 so it is slightly
better for y i still think it's terrible
in this case we're going to play queen
to f4 or excuse me queen to f5
this is the best square for it stays
relevant in the game protects the pawn
on f4 also attacks the c2 square which
really hinders where this queen can come
to you know queen to e2 we're going to
be blocking it with one of our bishops
we can castle on the king side
and then just max pressure on the c2
square which is not going to be moving
all that much
so that's how we're going to play if
they decide to go ahead and play bishop
takes on d5 if instead maybe they played
knight to c3 same thing as before
we're not worried about
keeping that isolated pawn on d2
instead we're just going to go ahead and
take after they take we're going to
exchange and we're going to play bishop
to d6 very similar that you saw before
the main difference yes they do have the
bishop on c4 that's fine we still up a
pawn and material
and we have a pretty good position
especially after we castle on the king
side
last thing you could see is after we
play
our pawn or our knight taking on d5 they
could play pawn d4
trying to attack this pawn on f4 now
we're just going to go and play knight
to c6 develop some of our other material
in the game they can castle on the king
side we're gonna play bishop here to uh
e6 and we're in a fine spot now some of
the threats that we have now we have
knight to e3
this is forking both the rook and the
queen it's also a discovered attack with
the bishop on e6 and yes they can take
with their bishop but then we take back
on e3 and we just have so many threats
that white has to deal with also in this
spot you can see black is up a pawn in
material
so white has to really worry about
how do they get that material back when
they don't really have the initiative
the last variation we are going to go
over instead of the bishop coming to c4
is if they don't try to protect this
pawn at all and they just try to get
aggressive and play bishop to
uh b5 now you can probably see that
knight to c6 is not going to work
terrible move we also don't want to
block things off with bishop to d7 or
even knight to d7 that that would
probably be the the worst of all the
options as far as playing it so we're
going to play pawn c6
i think they're pretty much always going
to take on c6 and then we're going to
take with our knight on c6
now they have a couple options from here
uh the first one i think would be
pawn d4
just opening up for that dark square
bishop to attack the pawn on f4
as soon as they do this i think we play
bishop to d6 defending the pawn on f4
you can see that
they can make some big mistakes here one
thing that a lot of players like to do
is if you have a piece that's pinned
this knight on c6 is pinned they like to
attack it with another piece so in that
case d5 makes a lot of sense hey this
knight is now trapped it can't move it's
pinned down to the king
but this would actually be a pretty big
mistake
because first we can go ahead and take
with our knight and if you look at it's
like okay well are you really going to
allow me to just take your knight here
but as soon as the queen takes this is
a basic concept in chess but it's the
idea of the discovered attack and so
bishop to b4 check
and the queen is going to fall pretty
much the best move that white has now is
just to play queen comes back to d2 and
then they're going to lose the queen so
that's going to be a terrible move they
should definitely not do that so they
can't just play
d5 although it does look tempting
you're almost baiting them to play that
by playing bishop to d6 instead
they should really just castle so you
know castle on the king side that's
completely fine
but let's come back let's say instead of
d4 they play knight to c6 okay we can
still play our bishop to d6
in preparation if they want to play the
pawn pushing forward here to d4 we're
we're going to be castling on the king
side in this version we're not going to
be castling on the queen side we don't
have as much of an uh the initiative as
we did before
but you can still see we have a pretty
good setup
both sides are equal in material
we have uh once we cancel on the king
side we're going to have a lot of safety
and we're not under any threat this is
why the king's gambit modern defense is
really thought of a safe defense for
black you don't have to worry about a
lot of the crazy lines and the typical
kings gambit variations that you usually
see
but it tends to be less popular i'm not
sure exactly why that is
for black because i do think it plays
extremely well so if you're someone that
plays against the king's gambit a lot i
think you should try to give this one a
shot
i think because a lot of white players
don't know
know how to attack it properly they're
really confused when they don't have any
initiative at all so
it's a good one hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video i love covering the
king's gambit variations again it is my
favorite opening in all of chess and i
just love different ways to attack and
defend against it hopefully you enjoyed
this video if you did if you wouldn't
mind hitting that like button let me
know in the comments below that you
enjoyed if you have other
recommendations on videos please let me
know those as well always looking for
variations that you guys want me to do a
video on but thanks again for watching
i'll see you in the next video